Scientists have recently discovered two gene
variants that are more common in gay men than
straight men, adding to the evidence that
homosexuality is, at least, partially genetic.
This news may actually sound familiar to you,
as studies in the early ‘90s also identified
regions on the 8th and X-chromosomes that
were correlated with homosexuality.
But the genes identified this time are on
the 13th and 14th chromosomes, and it’s
the first time ever scientists have identified
specific genes, not just a region on a chromosome
that could be correlated with sexuality.
The genes were found by comparing the DNA
of 1077 gay men with the DNA of 1231 straight
men, looking for variations as small as a
single nucleotide.
The gene on chromosome 13, called SLITRK6,
is active in a region of the brain called
the diencephalon; that same region contains
the hypothalamus.
The SLITRK6 gene has been shown to be active
in the hypothalamus of male mice fetuses days
before they’re born, which is thought to
be a crucial time for sexual differentiation.
The other gene scientists identified is called
TSHR, and it’s mainly active in regulating
the thyroid, an endocrine gland in your neck.
The thyroid releases hormones that control
your metabolism, and there is a thyroid condition
where the TSHR gene doesn’t function, leading
to an overactive thyroid and weight loss.
This condition, called Grave’s disease,
is more common among gay men.
So these recently pinpointed genes fit nicely
with past research, but it’s possible to
have these variants and not be gay.
By our current understanding homosexuality
is influenced by many genes, each having a
small effect.
And the environment probably plays a role
too.
You may have noticed that I never mentioned
any studies involving women, and that’s
because the science on female homosexuality
is lagging behind.
So as always, more research is needed, but
in this case don’t go googling it at work,
leave this one to the pros.
The evidence that several genes could contribute
to homosexuality may explain why some people
are bisexual too.
Thanks for watching, be sure to come back for more, and
I'll see you next time on Seeker.